so is the third wave already in Retreat
we had been told to prepare ourselves
for 100
000 daily cases in August but they've
been falling for the last six days
they're now at just under 25 000 down
from 40 000 a week ago the downturn is
even more pronounced in Scotland cases
have almost halved since peaking at the
end of June there is a bit of a health
warning on the numbers though not all
data points the same way at least not
yet the office for National statistics
randomly test people whether or not
they've had symptoms their results
showcases are still Rising across the UK
including Scotland where one in 80
people were infected up from 1 in 90 a
week earlier and the Zoe symptom app
which also looks at reported symptoms
suggests they're still Rising across the
UK so what could explain the drop in
daily numbers is it the vaccine well
uptake is already leveling off in the
age group most likely to have virus with
just 58 percent of 18 to 25 year olds
having had a jab and most children won't
be vaccinated at all so while some young
people will have antibodies from a
previous infection herd immunity is
unlikely to be the reason for the
falling cases what about the football
then the June surge in cases coincided
with the Euros often watched of course
in crowded pubs and fan zones Scotland
went out at the group stage a week later
cases started dropping England were in
it to the final again a week or so later
cases started falling there seems to be
a clear link what about summer holidays
particularly in the great weather we've
been having in Scotland schools broke up
around the 24th of June again just
before cases started falling in England
the inner term wasn't officially until
last week but 840
000 pupils were already at home
self-isolating and some schools closed
early coinciding with the downturn in
cases
there may be another Factor the number
of tests being done has dropped five
percent over the last week with schools
out children aren't testing twice weekly
so some cases may be being missed the
Prime Minister has said we're not out of
the woods yet and cases could rise again
as a lifting of lockdown starts to
filter through to the data possibly
later this week but let's hope the
numbers keep pointing the right way